714 .... CRUNCH-CRUNCH
*Markimoo eating noises*
unholy lip smacking
OK-
O NE MoRe
*more unholy chewing*
*walks into a very public place*
tHEse aRE gODDAMN GoOd pretZels.
man they GUD
uH hang on ;0
ONE MORe -more unholy markimoo sounds-
this man mADD.
Maybe one more.... (thats what you said a couple minutes ago -.-)
-asmr MARK version-
That was a small one. that was a small one i had..
stop pretzel abuse
oooHooh A+
what the fuck is the crowd waving at.
AHH forget the game
Hang on! *many more unholy mark noises lol help*
*jacksepticye slaps his stomach- (i ship them lmao)
Now THATS a slice of something pretzel
YEHaHah
*mark mumbling* (lol mark you okay?)
YahA hAh
EH, one more (you said that multiple times, mark. its time to stop.)
... I can do one more....
Mmm ...
MMM ... auUuuah
woAh
oH!!!
iTS EVEn BETTEr thAN the first (how though, mark?)
*intense pigeon flash backs activate*
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO--
(OOF)
Yeah, one more! (im surprised he hasnt run out of those)
*Crunch.*
Are you a scientist!? (thats a docor, markiboi)
*Music plays why the doctor is S H O O K*
You ever just ...
You ever just eat a pretzel? (well naw, mark.)
One more, one more ... I can't just ...(ITS TIME TO STOp)
Mark: *keeps eating the pretzels*
Doctor: *says hello to the pretzel god in pretzel heaven*
AhHH!
I gotta wash it down.
Got too much pretzel in my gob ... *you mean you belly?*
*Casually drinks IV fluid-* (mark tHAT IS nOT gud)
*Non-existant elevator music-i mean scp music xxxxxxddddddddd*
You ever feel like you're forgetting something?
𝘐'𝘭𝘭 𝘥𝘰 𝘵𝘸𝘰 𝘢𝘵 𝘰𝘯𝘤𝘦...- *WALRUS*
Now it's stuck all in my teeth!...
*crunch* (what did we say about biting people mark?)
Nom-Nom -.-
*Some pornhub shit.*
Oh, oh...
THAT'S STILL DRY
*slorp* AH, iT'S STILL DRY!
Is this dry ...?
It's really dry ...! (Its human flesh mark. Please stop biting them.)
Hang on, this is gonna take a bit. *bLINK*
*the moon rises*
It's really in there ... hang on! (I feel bad for this person)
a H!!!
𝑯𝑨𝑵𝑮 𝑶𝑵!
Let me try three.
*Dis bish*
* S H O O K !*
*C R O N C H* *grandma got oofed*
It's even dryer!! (Dont call old people dry ... das rude)
It'S MoRE DRY!!
It-
IT-
It's wORSE!!! (ITS AN OLD PERSON, THE SKIN CAN BE DRY AND WRINKLY)
YOU TRICKED ME
Youtrickedme
I've been ℎ𝑎𝑑
It's so dry.
it's like a desert
AGHHH
Just ... LIke it COULD be ... Just Sand
Inside them
Its still dry!! (sigh)
*sits on the floor*
*burps* UH-Ah (You enjoying them, mark)
*le silence*
That was borderline unpleasant (if its so unpleasant to you, just stop.)
*Sighs and smacks lips*
Yea ... one more ... ( ITS TIME TO STOP)
*cronch*
ITS DRY!!!
*soft music*
(shitty subtitles by : Bxbble Tea. Sub to mark and pewdiepie c;)
hope you liked those pretzels ;3